[Music]
if you've been watching the show for a
while you know that some of my favorite
guests include people who are firmly on
the political left such as sam Harris
Brett Weinstein and Eric Weinstein some
people who are on the political right
such as Ben Shapiro Dennis Prager and
Larry elder as well as some people who
are hard to place on the conventional
spectrum such as Jordan Peterson Phil
DeFranco and Brandon O'Neil of course if
you've been watching for a while you
also know that I think that the
left-right paradigm of politics is
becoming increasingly meaningless and
the new more relevant spectrum is one of
personal freedom versus state power
you're either for a society based on
laws which treat individual people
equally with minimal involvement from
the government in their day-to-day lives
or you prefer a society which treats
certain groups differently based on
immutable characteristics and thus the
government must play a major role in
whether they succeed or fail the
simplest way to say this is you're
either for your own determination or you
want to hand it off to someone else if
I've changed on anything in the past few
years it's that I consistently find
myself agreeing with people who fight
for individual choice over governmental
authority if you watch cable news or
really listen to any of the mainstream
media this conversation about your
ability to live your life as you see fit
which I believe to be the most important
conversation happening right now is
barely happening at all actually I
believe almost nothing of real value is
happening anywhere in mainstream media
cable news is force feeding you an
endless back-and-forth by pundits who
consistently get everything wrong
remember Hillary's 99% chance of winning
in 2016 while at the same time they mask
their opinions as facts and argue about
the endless minutiae of a broken
Washington DC instead of arming you with
real knowledge and new ideas I don't
know that there's anyone specifically to
blame for this other than the mainstream
media is based on an old dying model
that is being replaced by new media and
new technology so quickly that its
faults are becoming glaringly obvious
fortunately thanks to youtube podcasting
and however else you get show
like this one the mainstream media's
stranglehold on information which really
is a stranglehold on your ability to
think clearly about the issues of the
day is crumbling at an incredible rate
now the question is who and what will
replace it a few months ago one of my
favorite people to sit across this table
from Eric Weinstein came up with the
phrase intellectual dark web to describe
this eclectic mix of people from Sam
Harris to Ben Shapiro to his brother
Brett Weinstein to jordan Peterson all
of whom are figuring out ways to have
the important and often dangerous
conversations that are completely
ignored by the mainstream it's why I
would argue that this collection of
people are actually more influential at
this point than whatever collection of
cable news pundits you can come up with
and it's not just those names I
mentioned above but people like Joe
Rogan who's absolutely killing it on his
podcast every week
it's people like christina hoff sommers
who's fighting the intersectionality of
third wave feminism while still holding
hope for feminism's original ambitions
of equality of opportunity it's also
people like James d'amour and Lindsey
Shepard who are fighting for the true
diversity of ideas at Google and at
universities this wide tenth of people
were talking about have tremendous
political differences when it comes to
taxes abortion foreign policy and more
but we've all committed ourselves to
fighting for our ideas honestly and
passionately but more importantly than
that we've committed to the open
exchange of ideas and not silencing our
opponents no matter how many times they
refuse to extend that same courtesy to
us if you think I'm being hyperbolic
about the growing influence of this
group just check the traction that these
people get on Twitter or Facebook
compared to our mainstream competitors
Twitter may not be real life as I say in
my Twitter bio but it is some barometer
of what the zeitgeist is right now not
only will the numbers stand on their own
but when you realize that the mainstream
people were talking about have massive
amounts of money and influence behind
them and all most of us have is
grassroots support from people like you
you can really see what's happening here
even look at this very show we've come
together because we're fighting for our
ability to agree to disagree
before it's taken away from us
last year I talked about a new center in
politics a place where liberals
libertarians conservatives anyone who
wanted to fight authoritarianism could
put aside their differences and come
together to find some new solutions as
we watch our old institutions of
politics and media crumble I now realize
that the answer I was looking for wasn't
purely political but really cultural as
well there's something else happening
here that we all kind of know but we
haven't been able to totally define it's
why you watching this right now are
actually part of this intellectual dark
web if you engage with these ideas and
you're trying to figure out what the
hell is going on then you are as much
part of this thing as I am the more you
tweet share posts and get out there and
fight for what you believe the more
space that we have to continue to do
whatever it is each of us are doing
there are markers where some of this
breaks through to the mainstream such as
Ben Affleck's gross and racist comment
hurled at sam harris or when ben shapiro
Smackdown piers morgan about guns on CNN
or just this past week when jordan
peterson calmly dissected an interviewer
who was trying to paint him as an
extremist for defending free speech i
suspect there will be many more moments
like that this year because the
mainstream is finally picking up on what
you and I already see as I said at the
beginning of the year I believe 2018
will be the year of unusual alliances
and this new intellectual dark web will
be at the forefront of that movement
tomorrow I'll be in studio with two of
those guys ben shapiro and jordan
peterson and i fully expect to crash the
internet or at least get demonetised by
YouTube
[Music]
you